we end season four with a tease ahead at
season five i know you don't want to
give too much away but i remember
talking to you season three you're like
i like to stay out of it i don't want my
life to become you know the main story
on the show
jason that season five tease it's all
about your personal life well let's put
it this way i'm while i'm not
someone who's very comfortable
kind of sharing as much as the other
women my personal life i'm very
comfortable with grishall um so i think
that made it a lot easier on me did you
guys hear the news
no less news
it's insane to me i don't know what to
say i knew before they told me so weird
though but like exciting but like so
right i'm not getting into that you know
we're not criminals we're not doing
anything wrong
[Music]
did you ask me like a year ago if i ever
see myself going you know having a
relationship exposed on camera like
f no that the producers at one point
asked me to go on a date you know on one
of the seasons and i said no but you
know things changed and i'm just
extremely comfortable with her and i you
know we have just just such deep trust
and respect that i just it doesn't if
there's one person on the planet i think
i'd be comfortable
putting my relationship out there with
on camera it's her so she's made it you
know easier on me and i've and we get
into it and there are definitely some
scenes where you know they're very
personal um but
i found myself
to be way more comfortable than i
thought i would be and i i i have to
credit kershaw for that
well you have the show in common too
it's not like you're bringing in
somebody who has to understand that
whole world it's you guys already speak
that shorthand of what it's like to make
the show on top of live your lives so i
think that probably was a
one less barrier to entry i guess you
know we have real
um
things that were that we're dealing with
and working out and discussing and we do
that on the show
and i i guess i don't know why but i
definitely was comfortable more
comfortable than i thought i would be
doing that how much of
that kind of you guys
falling for each other are we going to
see because the tease implies that it's
a shock to the office it was a shock to
the office
um i had told
mary
my brother
and i guess there's then
it was
some people knew
or thought you know so i think
outside of those two clear people
knowing then there was kind of just a it
was a
different level of understanding for uh
for everyone else um and then for some
people it was just totally out of the
blue
and that was on purpose i mean we
we wanted to be careful for so many
different reasons
before going public who made the first
move
we argue about this
but i'm probably going to have to go
with me on that i mean it was a very
it was kind of a
i'm trying to remember to try to think
about actually how detailed i want to be
but i think i leaned in for the first
kiss i i'll put that on me
okay
so was it kind of a slow build that
you're just spending more time as
friends and it turned into something
even after we had been friends for so
long i don't think either of us had it
on our radar at all there was a night
that you know we kissed and i think it
was out honestly it was out of the blue
for both of us
uh so it was and then even then it was
like okay
this is just fun
um i don't think we were taking it too
seriously at that point either but no i
would definitely say
had you asked me
even a few
hours
before we first kissed if i was even
thinking about krishna romantically i
would have said no and i think she would
have said the same so it was a it was a
surprise to us
sounds like a spark flew with that kiss
we get these little moments in season
four that are made
from each of you of like longing glances
there's that hole she brings in simulu
for a consult
yeah and the camera keeps cutting away
to you how much of that is true and how
much is kind of creative editing for
this show definitely during season four
we were
you know i i don't remember the
timelines that well but certainly we
were
together or dating or
i don't again i'm so bad with with
dates but
and i think that there were some things
that
that
we did that we thought
would have made season four because we
thought maybe they were a little bit
more obvious and then there are some
things that we didn't think like
the simu uh scene where i think that
that production had some fun with that
let's put it that way
all right so this
it's interesting to try and piece
together this timeline did the kiss
happen on or off camera our first kiss
was not on camera okay yeah
what's your what's your favorite thing
about definitely not kiss krishna for
the first time
what's your favorite thing about her as
a partner now oh my gosh i mean there's
there's a lot um i mean this is the most
kind of fulfilling and rewarding
relationship i've ever been in she
i don't there's no there's certainly not
one thing but i would maybe just go with
like five i'd say that the level of
respect and admiration that i have for
her
um
and and love and trust
the communication and the honesty uh it
just feels very
and she's so
sweet you know i mean she's just a very
thoughtful like i'm just very happy
around her and that
is probably my favorite thing it's just
kind of how happy i am
around her but she just has a lot of you
know just very
impressive qualities i feel like i've
matured
more as a boyfriend and as a person and
someone in a relationship with her
so it's been a very rewarding
relationship for me in in for many
different reasons
how do you feel about
when season five comes out
seeing it all back and watching those
moments play out and now everybody
getting a chance to weigh in on it
don't really
i don't know i very thick skin
and i don't read
social media much or it's like so for me
like
i just care about
me and her and and my relationships uh
so that i've actually zero concern about
i've even thought about it to be honest
like it just is what it is and we're
very real i mean i think the audience is
gonna see us
and i have no problem with people
judging me for who i am
well it sounds like it's
everything you want in this moment in
your life and she checks a lot of boxes
and
you look very happy
thank you i get that a lot
um has getting romantically involved
complicated the work at all or not
because you kind of you know this how to
do this because of the merry of it all
yeah no it hasn't complicated the work
at all i mean it's just made it better
because you know we
we get to discuss we talk we have so
much in common obviously so we get to
talk about work when we're at home
um
but no i hasn't complicated it
at all maybe i'm being naive or maybe
i'm just forgetting a couple things but
quite honestly i would say it hasn't
complicated work at all i mean let's be
honest michelle and i share the same
best friends so it's
it's whether or not krishna and i were
together we'd probably be around all the
time anyway is she the one jason
i don't really know what that means but
i mean i'm in love with her
[Music]